là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins et si
vous ne réussissez pas ce qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée des valises à paris de
ce qui lui arrive à la bulle
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine c'est l'inattendu et vous
êtes les bienvenus à mes côtés tariq ali
et ludivine lopez journaliste à la
rédaction de l'ina bonjour à tous les
deux a alors voulu divine c'est le coup
d'état en birmanie qui vous a interpellé
un coup d'état militaire et
l'arrestation de la première ministre
hansen souci c'est la fin de la fragile
transition démocratique qui n'a duré que
dix ans et le retour de la dictature car
ce n'est pas le premier coup d'état dans
le pays en 1988
l'armée avait aussi pris le pouvoir par
la force et en forme succi alors
militante faisaient déjà partie des
personnes arrêtées après un mois de
concession qui n'ont pas réussi à calmer
les manifestants
c'est de nouveau la manière forte qui
fait la loi en birmanie en quelques
heures il y aurait eu plus de 100 morts
de part et d'autre les manifestations
sont transformés en combats de rue avec
l'armée élan reste sans nouvelle des
chefs de l'opposition et notamment de la
pasionaria birman
cet intellectuel de 43 ans fille du
héros de l'indépendance formés et marié
en occident est considérée comme la
choria kino de birmanie
dans une interview exceptionnelle faite
il ya quelques jours elle donnait ses
objectifs
je ne suis pas un leader de parti
politique je n'ai pas envie de diriger
un parti politique voilà même à
l'échelle nationale pour le moment ce
que nous voulons avant tout c'est la
démocratie
alors cette année là en dessous de 6
devenu la figure de l'opposition face à
la dictature militaire
tariq vous avez choisi de nous parler
d'une fête la chandeleur alors rares
sont les personnes qui savent encore à
quoi correspondent à ce rendez vous
sinon qu'il est aujourd'hui associé à
une tradition et surtout à une recette
une recette la fameuse recette des
crêpes 1 vous vous en doutez et avec la
chandeleur c'est un peu le début de la
saison des crêpes tout simplement gamme
et pour ton justement en abuser sans
trop de centres de conséquence est
nuisible pour vous pour nous j'ai repéré
un article sur le site internet du
magazine elle qui nous proposent des
astuces de pâtes un peu légères alors
mois des crêpes régine ans maintenant
vous allez voir mais je vais vous
proposer une recette qui n'a absolument
pas d'atouts minceur c'est une recette
je devins d'une grande figure de la télé
culinaire c'est raymond oliver en 1954
il nous propose des crêpes à la vanille
n'est pas que l'ovalie n'est qu'un
élément du formol et le parfum est
composé de deux choses autre chose
c'est-à-dire de trois éléments a hérité
en tout dany n'est ce pas alors il faut
en mettre beaucoup parce que les crêpes
est un des très très fine et le chauffe
beaucoup dans la poêle et le phare tout
en étant volatile pour qu'il y en ait un
peu il faut en mettre beaucoup et puis
c'est une recette landaise et malgré que
c'était dur à cette lan décès durant qui
rentre comme par contre et sipa loyer ou
jamais
environ 1300 us ou 2 fois plus que je né
me dany c'est à dire un tiers environ a
ni deux tiers de rompre en tout bien
tout ça doit donner un très grand ouvert
un très grand vin de bordeaux c'est à
dire pas loin d'un quart de litre
voilà un quart de litre dépend de la
taille du litre parce que là il y va
vraiment à l'oeil sur la lice sur le
relais en place qu'on ne voit pas dans
le sud de l'archipel qui n'ajoute de la
bière bien sûr ou d'ailier la pâte et
encore une fois a vu comme ça
la vérité est au fond de la marmite tard
et voilà ça c'était pour l'actualité de
la semaine et que s'est il passé le 3
février à travers le temps regardez
c'est le zapping de l'ina et ça s'est
passé à 3 février bonjour
gagnant la haute mer le navire long de
316 m et déplaçant 56 mille tonnes
atteint rapidement sa vitesse de
croisière
si certains passagers apprécient malgré
le vent le soleil des ponts promenade
les autres préfèrent à l'abri des ponts
couverts se livrer au confort des
chaises longues ou en joie du footing
[Musique]
il y à sept blessés ils sont touchés aux
jambes et à la tête
deux hommes et une femme sont dans un
état préoccupant car ils perdent
beaucoup de sang mais on a du moins
éviter l' incendie car le système de
sécurité a noyé la galerie marchande
sous des trombes d'eau je pense qu'il
est grand temps de cesser de punir les
vietnamiens pour nous avoir battus il y
a vingt ans de la façon dont il en parla
c'est magnifique ça a l'air raisonnables
mais comme un ancien combattant je ne
peux m'empêcher de me sentir trahi nos
caméras de direct pour la première fois
découvre les lumières de la ville les
lumières de rennes c'est en direct avec
cette caméra que nous allons passer une
partie de la soirée c'était l'idole du
monde arabe
c'était l'étoile du maroc comme on dit
et puis nous sommes très tristes
c'est une grande date pour la chanson
pour soir et demain
[Musique]
c'est une année noire pour l'or blanc en
france les vacances d'hiver débutent et
les stations de ski sont toujours à
l'arrêt alors même s'il n'ya pas de
contraintes de circulation pendant ses
congés les réservations sont en chute
libre presque -70% un gros coup dur pour
les professionnels de la montagne il
faut savoir que l'industrie de la neige
générant chiffre d'affaires de 10
milliards d'euros chaque année un
secteur qui a commencé à se développer
et c'était dans les années 50 ludivine
exactement c'est à cette période qu'on a
commencé à avoir ses complexes skiable
avec remontées mécaniques avec des
logements de masse avec des pistes
damées de quoi attirer professionnels et
amateurs et surtout démocratiser la
pratique du ski
l'état français va bien sûr flairé
l'intérêt économique des sports d'hiver
il lance le plan neige au début des
années 60
objectif multiplier les hébergements et
les équipements et ainsi pallier à
l'exode rural une dizaine de stations
vont alors sortir de terre la plagne les
menuires val thorens avoriaz en 1966 un
reportage était d'ailleurs consacré à
cette dernière son créateur le skieur
est champion olympique jean vuarnet
innovait pour attirer les foules jean
vuarnet vous venez de faire le tour de
la station d'avoriaz avec un moyen de
transport peu commun pourquoi
et bien si vous voulez c'est
l'illustration au final devant nous dans
nos trois grands principes qui régissent
l'implantation d'avoriaz à savoir la
station sans voiture pour bien frapper
l'imagination dont on fait venir des
rennes de laponie finlande avec de
traîneaux très typique que vous avez vu
un instant avoriaz station s'en va dire
c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
exactement dans les années 60 avec un
dock son architecture ultra moderne et
ses remontées mécaniques à ab qu'annick
avoriaz voit arriver des cars entiers de
touristes
le gratin parisien s'y retrouvait aussi
vous voyez ici un nicoletta johnny
halliday eddy barclay sacha distel en
1968 et en 1968 justement un autre
événement va participer au développement
des sportives ce sont les jeux
olympiques d'hiver lui de grenoble
un moyen encore une fois de booster les
projets de modernisation en station pour
promouvoir le tourisme et accroître la
renommée internationale de la france en
matière de sports d'hiver
la ville de chamonix en récoltait les
fruits en 1971 pour le plus grand
bonheur de son maire l'alpiniste maurice
herzog
c'est ainsi que dans la vallée de
chamonix on parle surtout américains
actuellement et nous ne nous en
plaignons pas car ce sont des hôtes
charmant qui en valait 1 vaïsse
pacifiquement notre vallée et nos pistes
de ski et qui sont tout à fait gentil et
est vraiment épatant vis-à-vis de la
population l'avez entendu maurice herzog
parlait d'envahissement pacifique on le
constate avec ces chiffres en 1964
860000 séjour aux sports d'hiver étaient
vendus onze ans plus tard en 1975
c'était trois fois plus soit deux
millions sept cent soixante huit mille
séjour est écoulé mais qui dit tourisme
de masse dit aussi station bondée
bouchons sur la route et aux remontées
mécaniques à la télévision plusieurs
reportages sont consacrés à ces usines à
ski à skis un terme que n'aimait pas
trop le responsable de la station de
cauterets dans les hautes-pyrénées en
on peut dire que le quota n'est pas une
usine à ce qu'ils refusent d'être une
usine à ce qui est parisien cette
clientèle est peut être souhaitable à
condition qu'ils ne se reproduisent pas
sous forme d'avalanche
on peut en absorber certainement bon non
mais encore faudrait-il d'absorber à
petites doses et peu à peu on voudrait
que le parisien s'acclimatent et
prennent l'ambiance et les habitudes de
la station avant que d'imposer leur mode
de vie
alors c'est ce qui s'appelle la rançon
de la gloire c'est intéressant parce que
cet afflux touristique grandissant
inquiète les spécialistes de
l'environnement
parce que pour accueillir tout ce monde
il a fallu construire encore et encore
les tours de béton envahissait les
alpages quelques voix s'élever contre
cette industrialisation c'était le cas
en 1973 dans cette émission au nom
évocateur la france défigurée sur le
magazine d'information précurseur
traiter de questions environnementales
cet architecte de l'alpe d'huez il ans l
alerte
l alpe d'huez nous sommes sur un terrain
particulièrement fragile parce que le
site et sans aucune végétation et toutes
les constructions qu'on implante l'alpe
d'huez ont un impact dans le site
considérable malgré ces avertissements
l'industrie de l'or blanc continuer son
essor en 1975 la france comptait 200
stations de sports d'hiver contre 50 en
le plan neige avait donc bien porté ses
fruits mais les alertes environnementale
continuait de s'intensifier de
s'amplifier
au point qu'en 1977 le président valéry
giscard d'estaing décide d'intervenir il
stoppait le plan neige et proclamait la
spécificité de la montagne écoutez le
c'était à bas luis dans les hautes-alpes
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
permettre un meilleur entretien et une
meilleure protection de ce patrimoine
naturel c'est toute la montagne qu'il
faut protéger pour lui permettre de
mieux vie oui c'est intéressant parce
qu'aujourd'hui 44 ans plus tard et bien
le l'industrie de la montagne est encore
plein de questions et s'interrogent
notamment sur son avenir aura pont de la
neige demain
oui parce que en ces temps de
réchauffement climatique et de pandémie
l'économie de l'or blanc bascule
certains acteurs de la montagne appelle
donc à repenser le domaine skiable
français une tribune a même été publiés
ces derniers jours par des élus et des
professionnels du secteur
leur volonté à court terme être moins
dépendants du tout ski en station et
développer des activités à faible impact
environnemental
merci beaucoup ludivine pour ses
explications
[Musique]
comment désamorcer la crise qui couve au
sein de l'éducation nationale un
processus de concertation a été lancée
en octobre dernier le grenelle de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer veut
remettre les enseignants au coeur de la
société rémunération reconnaissance
effective recrutement ce ne sont pas les
sujets qui manquent en attendant de
connaître les conclusions du collège
d'experts mobilisés par ce grenelle et
bien certains enseignants regarder ont
déjà choisi de faire grève c'était il ya
quelques jours
bonjour nathalie mons vous êtes
professeur de sociologie vous présidez
le conseil national d'évaluation du
système scolaire est ce qu'un grenelle
va suffire pour mettre fin à tous ces
problèmes
c'est un point c'est un bon point de
réfléchir et puis surtout de se
concerter je crois que ça c'est un point
qui est extrêmement important et il ya
des attentes qui sont fortes évidemment
sur ces sujets de la part des personnels
de l'éducation les enseignants
l'ensemble des cas des inspecteurs les
chefs d'établissement il est clair que
il ya une réponse qui est attendu il ya
peut-être beaucoup de questions par
rapport aux solutions possibles quand
même ça va être difficile de résoudre
tous les problèmes sur un seul grenelle
alors oui évidemment c'est beau c'est
très très court 1 mais je crois qu'il ya
une vraie volonté de poser les dossiers
à plat de les observer et ce qui est
important
finalement pour la première fois de se
projeter dans le temps voilà qu'est ce
qu'on va faire sur les 5 premières et
poussera les prochaines années dans ce
domaine là quoi alors la question de
rémunération restent importants la
priorité presque de ce grenelle le
salaire des enseignants
c'est d'ailleurs un problème récurrent
thalys est un problème récurrent il a
qu'à voir nos archives ap pour nous en
rendre compte
on en parle beaucoup aujourd'hui on en
parlait déjà beaucoup en 2016 je passe
mes vacances mais week end sur à
travailler pour la classe donc
finalement je trouve que c'est légitime
d'avoir cette augmentation salaires
cette augmentation de salaire cette
revalorisation la rva locaux comme on
dit dans le milieu
elle est en fait réclamé depuis les
années 80
notre image comme elle est à l'image de
notre salaire c'est à dire qu'elle sait
également dévalorisé et plus loin encore
dans nos archives en 1962 même si on
n'est pas dans un contexte social qui
touche toute la profession
un maître d'école évoquait déjà la
question et vous n'avez aucune amertume
de ne pas être mieux payé cher et vieux
pays
voilà pour les archives maintenant je
voudrais vous donner quelques chiffres
on va voir que dans le temps si on
regarde
globalement le salaire des enseignants a
augmenté il n'a fait qu'augmenter en bas
de cette courbe le salaire d'un
professeur débutant en eau
celui d'un professeur après 30 ans de
carrière et entre les deux on voit le
salaire médian des français donc on voit
que les trois courbes suivent
globalement la même évolution
en gros leur salaire a augmenté à ses
professeurs d'école mais ce n'est pas
vraiment une revalorisation c'est plus
que en fait on a suivi le niveau de vie
de l'ensemble des français pourquoi
cette situation à votre a dit nathalie
mons parce que les enseignants sont très
nombreux déjà l'éducation nationale
c'est quand même un gros paquebot et
quand vous prenez des décisions de
revalorisation ça pèse énormément sur le
sur le budget après je crois que en
termes de salaires ce qui est important
aussi c'est de comparer à ce qui se
passe évidemment à l'international c'est
à dire comment les enseignants dans
d'autres pays un sont payés on se rend
compte ainsi regard justement votre
première archives au milieu des années
sinal mans 2010 on a des enseignants
jeunes qui sont sous payés par rapport à
ce qui se passe dans les pays riches est
par contre des enseignants plus aguerris
qui ont un salaire tout à fait dans la
norme de ce qui se passe à l'étranger
d'où les revalorisations actuel voilà
depuis cette fin d année 2010 et si on
devait aller plus loin dans cette
comparaison entre les enseignants
français et leurs collègues européens
est ce que les français ont raison de se
plaindre ou est ce qui situe en matière
de rémunération justement alors il se
situe aujourd'hui on a revalorisé
vraiment les débuts de carrière parce
qu'il y avait un problème d'attractivité
c'est à dire voilà on avait quand même
de moins en moins
deux candidats pour aller dans les
concours donc du coup une baisse du
niveau de ses candidats donc ça c'était
un point finalement important
on s'est aussi posé la question de la
comparaison des salaires non plus à
l'étranger mais en france puisque en
fait les étudiants quand ils sont sur
les bancs des universités
ils choisissent aussi des carrières en
fonction des salaires qui vont leur être
proposées et on s'est rendu compte que
si les salaires au début était
finalement assez proches lorsque les
carrières se poursuivre
les enseignants sont handicapées par
rapport à d'autres carrières qu'ils
auraient pu embrasser par exemple s'il
est allé dans le privé le pays d'europe
où il fait bon vivre quand on est
enseignant
alors on à l'allemagne prix mail mieux
c'est
ces enseignants la finlande également
fin voilà on a le en dehors de l'europe
le japon paye très très bien c'est dans
ce cas la proportion par rapport à un
poste équivalent si si si c'est possible
c'est jamais très en décalage parce
qu'on se rend compte que dans tous les
pays
rares sont les professionnels qui vont
dans ce secteur pour la rémunération
parfaite 1 donc y'a jamais des décalages
extrêmement important par contre c'est
vrai que les débuts de carrière il faut
pouvoir attirer les jeunes
autre sujet sensible bien sûr les
conditions de travail des professeurs
des écoles tarifs que nous y est donc
les problèmes sont nombreux mais j'ai
choisi comme indicateurs le nombre
d'enfants par classe aujourd'hui il est
de 22,1 en moyenne par classe alors que
entre les années 80 et 2017 on était
plutôt autour de 23 enfants par classe
en tout cas ça a toujours était une
préoccupation un syndicaliste en parler
en 1981 déjà cédé difficulté
supplémentaire pour les maîtres
l'impossibilité dans certains cas de
suivre tel enfants qui se trouvent en
difficulté
alors nous nous pensons que des éléments
comme ceux là doivent être prises en
compte
de même qu'on devrait prendre en compte
la situation des locaux vous savez que
beaucoup d'écoles parisiennes sont venus
avec des locaux de dimension insuffisant
à cette époque là on a 23 enfants par
classe aujourd'hui 22,1 est ce qu'il y a
un nombre auquel on peut estimer qu'on
l'ait dans des conditions idéales pour
enseigner non c'est un sujet qui a été
énormément approché par la recherche
et ça n'est pas simple tout dépend de la
pédagogie que vous développez on voit
par exemple des pays qui sont toutes en
tête des classements de pisogne savez
cette enquête de l' ocde qui analyse les
acquis des élèves à 15 ans et on voit
par exemple des pays comme le japon il
ya des classes extrêmement importante
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont une autre
pédagogie un qui va permettre qui
s'appelle le tutorat ont fait des petits
groupes d'élèves et anciens de la classe
les plus avancés aide les plus en
difficulté et donc on peut comme ça
gérer une classe qui est plus importante
donc on a très peu d'éléments de
recherche qui nous montrent que la
simple en fait réduction de la taille
des classes est importante soit
actuellement c'est une politique par
exemple dans le primaire c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt bien 22 22 élèves par
classe est ce que c'est une réussite à
mettre à l'actif de l'éducation
nationale ou au contraire est-ce qu'il
n'ya pas de plus en plus de parents
peut-être qu'ils se tournent vers le
privé alors l'enseignement privé à des
tailles de classe beaucoup plus élevé un
systématiquement l'accord peut-être
aussi de leur succès voilà ils sont
peut-être victime de leur succès mais en
tout cas si on cherche des tailles de
classe limité c'est papa vers
l'enseignement privé qu'il faut se
tourner puisqu'elles sont plus
importantes
aujourd'hui on a une vraie politique
mais qui est très ciblée sur les élèves
en difficulté dans l'éducation
prioritaire puisque là on sait que dans
ces contextes particuliers
la baisse de la taille des classes peut
être importante puisque tout simplement
parce que l'enseignant a au lieu d'avoir
24 élèves devant lui vaincu en avoir que
12 et va pouvoir suivre chacun des
élèves
encore faut-il qu'ils aient la bonne
pédagogie pour que ce soit efficace
alors jean michel blanquer veut remettre
les enseignants au coeur de la société
ça veut dire quoi redonner à cette
profession son lustre d'antan tarifs oui
on peut dire ça quelque part en tout cas
c'est vrai que il
v cette image du maître de la maîtresse
qui était un notable dans la société à
l'époque une image qui a été véhiculé
d'ailleurs par la culture vous souvenez
peut-être de cette série l'instit
diffusée dans les années 90 avec gérard
klein donc ça c'est de la fiction mais
dans la réalité
moi j'ai une archive à vous proposer
bien sûr une archive de 1946 alors c'est
une avance gérard gérard klein ils
n'arrivent des actualités françaises
vous savez ces archives qu'on aime bien
vous montrer dans l'inattendu qu'on
diffusait à l'époque dans les cinémas
puisqu'on était tout simplement pas
équipé des postes de télé et souvent
dans un style un peu romanesque la voilà
cette archive aujourd'hui c'est le même
encore ou presque
l'instituteur mais il semble que nous le
voyons milieu où le croyant quand entre
ses classes il fit sur son vélo porté à
la ferme éloigner le bond chaussures ou
le bond de pneus apportés prendre note
de nécessité auquel on le prie de porter
rom est percé son métier non seulement
de faire la classe mais aussi d'être le
factotum du villa
le voyais encore le soir venu et le
village endormi il assiste le maire dans
l'administration de la commune car c'est
son métier non seulement de faire la
classe mais de veiller sur la vie du
pays un homme tout simple l'instituteur
un homme tout simple l'instituteur est
ce que au vu de tout ce qu'on s'est dit
depuis le début
on peut dire que cette profession a été
déclassé ou est-ce que c'est fort à
l'époque on voit bien c'est tout
l'imaginaire des hussards noirs de la
troisième république car la troisième la
france se construit aussi un graal ça à
ses enseignants c'est l'écrivain public
voilà donc à un niveau d'éducation
évidemment qui est beaucoup plus élevé
la part des uns des instituteurs de
l'époque que de la moyenne de la
population
or la population française est
heureusement un grâce à la
démocratisation d'enseignement le niveau
de formation de l'ensemble des français
assez développée aujourd'hui bon on a
des enseignants certes qui ont un master
mais la différence est vraiment tout à
fait beaucoup plus limité aujourd'hui
par rapport à celle qu'elle était
auparavant ça c'est clair
donc on a parlé de tous les problèmes de
la place de l'instituteur dans la
société
mais moi ce qui m'a marqué quand j'ai
préparé cette émission c'est que
n'importe quel archives ou presque
chaque fois qu'on parle de grèves de
manifestations il y a toujours ou
presque
un professeur qui nous parle de la
vocation on sent que c'est encore très
très fort cet amour du métier en
compilées dans les archives que j'ai pu
voir ça donne ça c'est une vocation
c'est la fois oui ça sert à quoi d'être
là prêtre c'est un appareil qui ont fait
ça parce que j'aime
institutrice elle est très séductrice
j'ai choisi ce métier parce que c'était
pour moi une vocation parce que j'y
crois parce que je crois tout de même
que l'éducation nationale c'est la base
d'une société ou de 32 ans de carrière
j'ai toujours autant de plaisir à
retrouver mes élèves
voilà pour l'amour du métier même de ce
côté là de la vocation
on sent que ça s'effrite un peu ou en
tout cas que ce n'est pas unanime en
2010 est par exemple 77 % des
enseignants trouvé que leur mission
avait du sens en 2020 on passe de 77 à
68 4%
ces quatre pour ça c'est quand même bien
rouille assez bon sens que ça descend et
que ce métier par vocation pur on
s'attendait à plus en tout cas la
vocation reste quand même très élevé
lorsqu'on a fait une enquête auprès des
des étudiants donc en 3e année
d'université ce qu'ils nous disent je
veux aller vers ce métier
ils étaient deux tiers à y penser depuis
l'école primaire pour ce qui devait
devenir instituteur ou après depuis le
lycée pour ceux qui s'adressait à
l'enseignement secondaire dos ça reste
quand même un métier de vraiment de
vocation et surtout c'est un métier qui
a du sens pour des seconds carrière on
en parle très brute c'est à dire des
gens qui ont finalement avancé 1 dans la
vie professionnelle compliquée un moment
se posent et se disent voilà 40 ans 50
ans mais j'aimerais finalement rentré
embrasser un métier qui a du sens on a
aujourd'hui un statistiques très peu
connu on a aujourd'hui une personne sur
cinq qui passe le concours de professeur
des écoles pour lesquels c'est une
seconde carrière parce que c'est un
métier qui continue à avoir du sens et
aujourd'hui les gens cherchent de plus
en plus de sens dans leur métier donc il
faut vraiment que l'éducation nationale
s'en empare et on va suivre bien sûr
avec la plus grande attention les
conclusions de ce grenelle de
l'éducation merci à vous nathalie mons
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
sociologie à vous pressez vous présidez
le conseil national d'évaluation du
système scolaire voilà avant de refermer
cette inattendue notre traditionnel
pépite une chanson tiens ça ira mieux
demain chanté par annie cordy pour
garder le moral tout simplement
demain comme tout finira bien
il faut profiter du jour 1
[Musique]
ça ira
6 à 2 ans
[Musique]
on se retrouve mercredi prochain 22
heures sur le canal 27 et toute la
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
sur france info ce lina émission
préparée avec les documentalistes anne
delavaux et florence lui c'est merci à
elle et merci à vous de votre présence
[Musique]